>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Nicholas Brown: Good
evening, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the Library of Congress.
Many of you are regulars.
Thanks for being here.
And some new folks as well.
My name is Nick Brown.
I'm a music specialist
and concert producer here.
Very pleased to welcome you
on behalf of the library
and also the Freer
Sackler Galleries,
who are co-presenting this
concert with us tonight
of musicians from Marlboro.
And I'd love to go down the line and
have everyone introduce themselves
and say what your instrument is
your name and where you're from.
>> Peter Stumpf: My name is Peter
Stumpf, and I play the cello and I'm
from Bloomington, Indiana.
>> Alexi Kenney: My
name is Alexi Kenney.
I play the violin, originally
from Palo Alto, California.
>> My name is Robin Scott,
and I also play the violin
from Indianapolis,
Indiana originally.
>> My name is Zoltan Fejervan.
I am from Hungary.
That's where I live right now.
>> Nicholas Brown: Oh, I knew I
couldn't say his name properly,
so I figured I would just like,
[laughs] leave it out there.
Wonderful.
So thank you all for being here.
You are four of the five
musicians for the evening.
And Shuangshuang will be onstage
later for you to enjoy her playing.
Can you tell us a bit about how you
came together as a chamber ensemble
within the context of Marlboro?
Did you work together before that?
Or did some of you work together?
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, actually
with the Marlboro tours often the
way they are structured is they're
based around a group that performed
at the Marlboro Music
Festival in the summer.
So, in this case the
Brahms, a major piano quartet
that we're playing this evening
was a piece that we've worked
on as a group already at Marlboro
for a certain number of weeks
and then performed there.
And that was sort of the
foundation of the tour group.
We added a violinist to fill out
the program for the first half
with the string quartets
that we're doing,
and that's Alexi Kenney
joined us for that.
So originally it was the Brahms,
[inaudible] Zoltan and Robin
and Shuangshuang and myself.
So that's how it came together.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
And how far into the
tour are you all now?
>> Robin Scott: Halfway
today, right?
Yeah. Third of five.
[laughs]
>> Nicholas Brown:
How's it gone so far.
>> Robin Scott: Fantastically.
>> Nicholas Brown: Yeah.
Great. [laughs]
>> Robin Scott: Couldn't be better.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
[laughs] And where
is next after D.C?
>> Zoltan Fejervan: We'll going
to do Philadelphia tomorrow.
We're playing there.
And so far all the places
we've played were so different.
So we'll look forward for the stage
version for our concerts today.
I have to say I really
love this hall actually.
It has a certain warm atmosphere
and also the sound is very warm,
so I think it's more
difficult to play not nice.
[ Laughs ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Cool.
So can you tell us a bit about
the thinking behind the repertoire
selection for this program?
So we have the Haydn and the
Brahms and the vaporing [sp].
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, the Bones
piano quartet is, you know,
one of his greatest
chamber music works.
I think it's very and it's
a very sophisticated piece
and it's a very, it's a big piece.
It's very, substantial.
And one of his longer
works actually.
So the idea is to keep the beginning
of the program, the first half
of the program on the shorter side
and also somewhat on
the lighter side.
And so for that reason the Haydn was
selected, the Haydn String Quartet,
which I think is a very
nice balance for the bonds.
And then the vaporing that we're
doing, the idea with that was
in part that it's brevity.
It's not as short as most
vaporing pieces are, but it is,
you know, a very compact work.
And also it's very rarely played
and very few people know it.
So that was sort of -- those
two elements were the two things
that were the basic idea
behind doing the vaporing.
I think in addition to that
though because the Brahms is
such a great piece it's important
to make sure that the pieces
that precede it are in that
realm and level of composition,
which I think both of these
without question are, you know,
said that was also
one of the reasons
for choosing the Haydn
and the vaporing.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
Have any of you worked
together in different settings
than the Marlboro tours
or the festival?
>> Robin Scott: Yes.
I've worked with Alexi
and with Peter.
Actually in a previous
Marlboro tour Peter and I came
to a [inaudible] gallery
a few years ago.
And so we played together for
six years, [laughs] on and off.
>> Alexi Kenney: Yes.
>> Robin Scott: And Alexi and
I have played together some
and some chamber context as well.
>> Nicholas Brown: Cool.
And so you all have very
interesting backgrounds.
Some of you have done
very well in competitions.
Some of you are doing a lot
of orchestra work or did.
When you have these kind of
different courses in your careers,
how do you think you approach
your creative process together
differently or similarly to other
chamber experiences that you have?
So like do you have in mind, oh,
this happened when we were
doing this Beethoven thing
with this conductor
and that was silly.
So let's not do that
here kind of deal.
[ Laughs ]
>> Alexi Kenney: I mean
I guess we all come at it
from different places, but
eventually at the end of the day
for me collaboration is king in
music, so all experiences stem
from chamber music in my opinion.
And so whether I'm playing a
solo Concerto with orchestra
or in an orchestra or
in a string quartet.
Obviously the way you approach
it is slightly different,
but I think if you come
at it with an open mind
and in a collaborative
spirit, then I don't know,
these things are all
kind of similar.
We don't have any issues
working together for instance,.
[laughs]
>> Nicholas Brown: Great, cool.
What kind of -- sorry, I'm going to
get silly with questions for a bit,
but what might be some issues
where you have very strong feelings
about that say the group
is on one side and one
of you is on a different position.
Would that be something
having to do with tempo,
performance practice
issues, articulation even.
Or do you kind of just
it's like a relationship.
You kind of give and
take and find a balance
and somehow have a nice
combo platter at the end.
>> Robin Scott: What you said
at the end is about right.
I think oftentimes also what
people perceive at the time
to be contradicting
ideas, oftentimes aren't.
There are many times in music
I think when you can try
to actually combine two things
that almost seem to be opposites.
But when you put them together
actually make something that's far
stronger than just one of
those things by itself.
I mean I often think that about
when you have people who think
about a piece very
differently, they're looking --
they're coming from a
different direction.
They're looking for a little bit
different things perhaps in it,
but when you get both of
those qualities actually,
you get a better product
than maybe what you thought,
how you thought you loved
it in the first place
when you take other
people's ideas into account.
And then you also are forced to find
out what you really
like about the piece.
Was it really the speed at which
it goes by that you like it.
Well, no, that's probably
not what it is.
It's other deeper things and then
you find you can actually do your
own ideas and add to them
other people's suggestions
and the product oftentimes is
much better than it was initially.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
So since we're in a library,
we're going to go a little nerdy
and you all just got to see some
cool manuscripts in the lobby
of the auditorium over here.
And for those of you who haven't
seen them yet, there are a variety
of Vayburn manuscripts out,
which are from the library's
Moulden Hour archives,
which is a very large archival
collection split amongst
institutions in North
America and in Europe.
And we have all kinds of
really cool stuff in there,
and just go to lsu.gov and put in
Moulden Hour in a very German way
and you will find it in
full collection guide.
But so these manuscripts
are there and you all kind
of mentioning the fact that
it's a unique thing to be able
to see the manuscripts when
you're going to perform next door.
And then on top of that Vaburn
manuscripts don't exactly
exist everywhere.
Like maybe some Mahler manuscripts
would or Beethoven manuscripts.
So what was that little
experience like for you,
because I got to watch
it and it was fun,
and we enjoy provoking
that for sure.
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, I mean it's
the manuscript issue is kind of,
I mean I was shocked to see
that, because, you know,
the issue with manuscripts is
that some of them are hidden away
in private collections, in
somebody's personal library.
So we don't have access to a
lot of manuscripts and in some
in some cases we don't
even know where they are
or if they even exist
for that reason.
There's no real organizational
sort of entity that controls that.
So to see that one I was really
surprised, because it's not
that well-known of a piece anyway,
but we were really impressed
by how very neatly written it was.
He was apparently very meticulous
about his copying and writing.
It's not one of these, you know --
>>
>> Nicholas Brown: Yeah.
[Inaudible]
>> Peter Stumpf: -- messy,
floppy looking manuscripts.
It was very, very fine.
And it was edited.
I mean there was some
editing in there.
>> Alexi Kenney: It's
also interesting
to me just knowing this piece
now and realizing how passionate
and how dark and depressing parts of
it are, [laughs] the tempo marking
or tempo marking at
the beginning is just
to [inaudible] which
is dark and heavy.
And to contrast that with the way
that he seemed to have conceived
or written it down
very daintily is kind
of funny [laughs] contrast for me.
>> Robin Scott: It's
also just interesting
to see the actual handwriting
of the composer that you play.
I think that adds to the
shock value of [laughs] it.
Today I and Zoltan went over
to the gallery and I was trying
to find individual brushstrokes
of Rembrandt, and then to see
that out there, it's
all pretty remarkable.
There aren't too many
places where you can go
and see this sort of stuff.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
Thank you for sharing
those reflections.
Where is some of the other venues
where you've experienced
something similar,
like have any of your
performed at the Morgan Library
or for other places like that?
Or is this it?
>> Robin Scott: I have played there,
but they didn't show me manuscripts
[inaudible] [laughs] I do know they
have some great, very
great manuscripts there.
>> Nicholas Brown: Cool.
So before we open up to Q&A
one more question for me.
And that is I'd love to hear
you guys discuss your experience
with summer festivals, and then
compare sort of your experience
with Marlboro versus those
other festival experiences.
I've had the opportunity to
some summer festivals and it's
such a unique, creative, vibrant
space where people kind of let go
of a lot of their inhibitions and
there's a much more social component
in different ways where you're
going to meet new people,
rather than the folks you're
working with all the time.
What about Marlboro offers an even
more unique festival atmosphere
for you?
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, Marlboro
is actually completely unique
as a festival.
In summer festivals there is a
range of different sort of concepts.
Some are educational, which
involve, you know, will have faculty
and students and their lessons
and student performances,
faculty performances.
Some festivals are just
professional where you go
when you perform chamber
music and oftentimes
in those cases you're
playing with people you may
or may not know very well, may have
played with before but maybe not.
And you're playing in a short
period of time rehearsing
and rather quickly putting
together a repertoire
and presenting it in a concert.
So those are the two kind
of ends of the spectrum.
Marlboro is kind of in a different
category, because the concept
of it is it's seven weeks long.
The first two weeks there
are no performances,
so it's just rehearsal.
Then the concerts begin from the
from the third week to the end
of the festival, so they
cover a span of five weeks.
And the program is only determined
ten days in advance of the concerts.
And the reason for
that is that the groups
that are rehearsing
decide amongst themselves.
You have complete control
over whether
or not you perform something.
You can spend the whole summer at
Marlboro and not perform at all.
You could just rehearse.
There's no requirement
to perform anything.
So you only perform if you feel
inspired as a group to do so.
And of course most groups are aiming
towards that possibility, but,
you know, it's not a requirement.
So we have an option to not
perform, which means that it's only
when it really feels right, you
know, that the group chooses
to offer it for performance.
Now having even if it's
offered for performance,
it isn't necessarily selected,
because then they have
to choose the program
that makes the most sense,
as some pieces even be
offered and not chosen
and those aren't performed.
And you really have
much more rehearsal time
than you would ever
have at most festivals.
So it's completely
different in that sense,
so the performances have a
different kind of aura about them.
They're not a group that's
rehearsed very quickly
and put something together.
They're not formed to a music
a group that's played together
for years, but they are a
group that's rehearsed a lot
and spent a lot of time
together on preparing the piece
and really not been under any
pressure to hurry to perform
so they can really delve
into it in great depth.
And then on top of all of
that, it's also a program
that involves younger
players and older players.
So there's a certain number
of older players who are kind
of in a somewhat of a mentor role
that are in each one of the groups.
There's one person like
that in each group,
and the others are very
talented and young players,
some very best from
around the world.
And what the idea is to really have
it be encourage them to rehearse
as peers and to work as like just a
group of musicians working together.
And the role of the mentor varies
from one group to the next,
so depending on the group itself.
If the group needs a lot of help
with something then they're there.
If they don't, they don't.
But then the person in that role
also plays somewhat of a role
in deciding about whether the
group is offered for performance.
But the group decides, they kind
of choose themselves to do that.
So that's just completely different.
And this was the, you know, kind of
the brainchild of Rudolph Serkin,
who had this idea and
it really is --
there are other festivals that have
tried to sort of do similar things,
but none of them do
exactly like this.
This is totally unique.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
Does anyone else have
some ideas or thoughts?
>> Zoltan Fejervan: And I think
[inaudible] everything was important
about Marlboro.
Maybe he didn't mention
the sona and the pound.
[laughs] So Marlboro provides
lots of things besides that also,
which makes it special and makes
somehow the participants feel
that they really belong
to that place.
And like socially get together
like you literally every day,
every night that we spend together.
So we are far away from big city,
away from like the
every days duties,
and it really somehow brings
this almost ecstatic feeling
of the everyday music making.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
I think we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
So if you have a question just
throw your hand up in the air
and my colleague Jay will
come around with a microphone.
>> On the vaporing how long
did it take to put it together?
How long did you practice on it?
And had any of you played it before?
>> Robin Scott: Peter had
played it before I believe,
but the rest of us I think
it was the first time.
We had a week.
Well five days.
About five days.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Robin Scott: Six days?
>> Peter Stumpf: Six days.
>> Robin Scott: Six days where
we rehearsed the Vaporing
and the Haydn every day.
And it came together
actually pretty well I think.
We had all done some
preparation on our own,
so that we weren't sight
reading when we came together.
>> Zoltan Fejervan: Right.
[laughs]
>> Robin Scott: So that
makes a big difference.
You haven't some clue of what to
do, but it came together very well.
It's not quite as complicated as
some of the more, the later more --
>> Peter Stumpf: Yeah.
>> Robin Scott: -- 12 tone
compositions, but it has a lot
of chromaticism in it, which
takes some figuring out for sure.
You really have to figure
out what you need to hear.
>> When was it composed?
>> Robin Scott: In 1905.
>> '05, okay.
>> Alexi Kenney: I actually
had never even heard
of this piece before.
>> Robin Scott: Yeah, so same here.
>> Yeah. I'm sure [inaudible]
>> Robin Scott: It's actually
it's written the same year
as another string quartet that he
wrote called Long Summersaults.
>> Yeah. That one I know.
>> Robin Scott: A slow piece.
And that's very, very romantic.
>> Yeah.
>> Robin Scott: And this is very
different from that, very traumatic,
largely, and yet written
the same year.
It's interesting I think to me.
>> Nicholas Brown: I'm just
going to keep asking questions,
and if you guys don't have ideas.
There you go.
>> Yeah. And I don't know
exactly what I'm asking,
but back in the '60s I used to
get and go up to the Marlboro
with my parents for all time.
And felt it was just unbelievably
amazing, because it was
like the musicians were able to go
up on the mountain and try to find
out what the hell was going on.
And then they'd work on
it, apparently much more
than your average group of guys
and then they'd come
back down and report out.
And it was incredible.
And I was wondering it sounds
like it pretty much the same,
and if you guys have some feeling
for that I'd be interested
in knowing.
>> Robin Scott: Yeah, there
is definitely that element.
I think one of the things I
love to do most there is to have
at least one group or one piece
that is a really big masterwork,
like a big Beethoven
quartet or partite quartet,
something that takes a lot of time
that justifies spending five, six,
seven, even weeks on it with a group
of musicians that you really love.
And then, you know that you've got
all this time and that you feel
that you really have a good
chance to do it justice.
I played a professional string
quartet outside of Marlboro
and sometimes we have to put
things together very quickly.
Even though we play all
the time together we have
to learn something very quickly
for an upcoming performance
and to have the flexibility,
the space of an entire summer
is a great luxury, frankly.
And you have the time to
form a sound as a group
that you don't really when you just
throw something together at a usual,
at a normal festival
or at some serious.
Even if the players are very good.
You really get to hash out and
discuss and try all sorts of ways
of doing things and you can
settle, you can find the flexibility
that oftentimes isn't
as easily accessible.
>> Nicholas Brown: Anyone else.
Oh, just once for the microphone.
>> I'm sorry I was a little late,
but just maybe you covered this.
But how are you chosen?
How do you get there?
Do you apply?
Do you have try outs?
Do you pay?
What is the situation?
[ Laughs ]
>> Peter Stumpf: So the way it
works is there are auditions
for the festival, and
that's primarily the way
that the participants are selected.
And they're required to
perform some solo works,
but also to prepare some
chamber music parts.
And they're given actually a limited
amount of time to prepare the parts.
So it may be a couple of weeks in
advance they get the repertoire.
I don't know, something like that I
think, and then and then they have
to -- and often it's difficult parts
[laughs] that they have to learn.
And then they perform those
as well in the audition.
There are also circumstances
where people are invited.
In some cases when they're younger
or more often when they're older
to sort of participate
as more of a mentor role
or if they're a younger person maybe
just someone has already achieved,
you know, a certain success as a
performer and they are just invited.
>> And are they funded?
>> Peter Stumpf: It is funded.
There is a tuition,
but nobody pays it.
[ Laughs ]
There is, for whatever
reason there is, yes.
There is actual tuition,
but it is always --
it's a full scholarship for
everybody that's involved.
>> What are the different
[inaudible]
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, [laughs] a
little bit of it comes from the NEA.
>> Robin Scott: Currently.
>> Peter Stumpf: And the rest of it
is from donations from, you know,
generous supporters and
corporations and things like that.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Peter Stumpf: Most arts
organizations these days.
Also the Marlboro College
provides the --
well we pay the Marlboro
College event.
That also has to be paid for, but
that's where people are housed
and then there's food and
everything provided through that.
>> Nicholas Brown: Anyone else?
>> [Inaudible] Another
kind of a question.
I sort of got the impression when I
was in Marlboro and you would talk
to people that because you
guys aren't provided a lot
of independence and time to figure
things out that there were people
who would say, well there was
a little bit of reluctance
to employ some people who've been to
Marlboro because they didn't see --
maybe the word isn't docile
enough, but [laughs] they would be
in an organization and they wouldn't
exactly be doing what they were told
to do, in a very good sense.
I don't mean having a grand time,
but I wondered whether you had run
into that at all in your
professional career.
[ Laughs ]
>> Robin Scott: On the record too.
[laughs] No, I don't think --
so is the premise that people who
have been to Marlboro are difficult
to work with or hard to employ or --
>> My thought was that,
yeah, there were --
let's see [inaudible] [laughs]
>> Nicholas Brown: It's like
[inaudible] making music.
Yeah.
>> Robin Scott: There are many
musicians who that could be said of.
[laughs]
>> Well I think that's a
very positive thing, but --
>> Peter Stumpf: It's
an interesting point.
You know, it's awful -- I think
that there could be some validity
to what you're saying, but I
think it's awfully hard to define.
You know, because it's sort of a --
it's a conceptual thing, you know.
But, yeah, I think that
there's a little bit
of validity there to that idea.
I think that it can be seen as a
kind of elitist kind of way of going
about things, you know, that's
very idealistic, you know.
But, on the other hand, you know,
so many fine musicians have gone
through there and I don't think any
of them are having a lot of trouble
with their employment fortunately.
So I think it's generally had a
real positive impact overall on.
I think it has quite
an important influence
in the musical community in general.
>> Nicholas Brown: Anyone else?
Last call or I'm going
to do another one.
OK. So for those of us who have
not yet been to the festival,
which is probably most of us
in the room and myself included
and I'm very eager to get there.
Would you recommend
going for a full weekend
and catching all the performances to
get a sense of everyone that's there
or would you recommend, you
know, go one day, one weekend,
one day, another weekend.
Go at the beginning of the summer,
go at the end of the session?
>> Alexi Kenney: You never know.
>> Nicholas Brown: Okay.
[laughs] And where are the
places to stay and hang out
and what museums are
around, that kind of thing.
>> Peter Stumpf: Well, the
closest town is Brattleboro,
Vermont which is, you know, an
interesting, you know, Vermont city.
And, you know, it's a funky
place, but very, you know,
there's actually great
restaurants there
and art galleries and all kinds.
It's artistic oriented community.
Marlboro itself has a
post office and an inn.
There is an actual inn right
there in the center, and a church,
so there's inn, church, post office.
And --
>> College.
>> Peter Stumpf: And then
the college, but that's not
in the center of the town.
The college you have to drive
to the college from there.
>> Alexi Kenney: It's really
in the middle of the woods.
>> Peter Stumpf: It's in the middle
of the woods up in the mountains.
So it's, yeah, it's
beautiful, quiet country there.
Bears and mooses.
[laughs] But, yeah.
So actually there, there
is only this one small inn
and then there are a
couple other inns nearby.
And there are people, a lot of
people that come up just to be
in Vermont and to go
to the concerts.
And some stay for the
whole summer to do that.
And some people just
come up for a weekend.
It's a great weekend trip.
You know, because then you can --
the Sunday concerts
in the afternoon,
so you can travel somewhere in
that evening if you need to.
And the Saturday concerts at night.
So it's really set up for people
to come up for the weekend,
and I think a lot of people
from New York do that, you know,
because they can just
go up for a weekend
and hear a couple of concerts.
So, you know, whenever
you have the time
and interest for I think really.
>> Nicholas Brown: Anyone
else any suggestions,
places to steer clear of.
[laughs] Okay.
So last question I'll throw out
and then we'll let you guys have
a little dinner break is perhaps a
controversial question,
but you don't have
to get political or anything.
How do you interpret your roles
in society as artists in terms
of what do you think your role is in
inspiring people to think critically
about their lives, about music
or about the way music
can affect positive change
or anything in that world?
If you have any thoughts
that don't cause you
to reveal anything too sensitive,
feel free to jump in there.
I think the reason for my
question is I think we're
in Washington, right.
So Washington is an
epicenter of a lot
of different things
going on in society.
For better and for
worse, and the Library
of Congress definitely
values the role of the arts
and culture in humanities.
And we really want to know where you
all are at and how we can complement
that work to really make sure
that we're serving the population.
I guess. Like education, work.
Do you do performances
for specific causes?
Do you steer clear of it all
and just focus on the music
and that's the way you deal with it.
>> Peter Stumpf: I think each one
of us does something
different, you know.
I mean we all have different
ways that can do that.
I mean at this point in my life
I'm a professor at the University.
So I mean what I'm doing
is, you know, mentoring
and helping young aspiring
musicians to participate in music,
and to get involved, and
to see it go forward.
And I think, you know, I
think probably most people
that are involved in the arts in
general it comes from a certain kind
of it's about inspiration that
comes from whatever the art
that that particular person is
drawn in by, whether it be visual
or musical or writing, whatever.
And so I think ultimately it's
in particular for what we do,
we're bringing something to life
that otherwise would not, you know,
there's no way to know what you --
there are a few people that can look
at a score and know exactly what
it sounds like and experience it
without ever having heard it.
[laughs] You actually can.
Some people can.
But generally it has to be played.
And there's such a huge range
of different areas of music
that people get involved in.
You know, it's just it's
endless and limitless.
But I think it's about the
inspiration and the connection
between what it affirms for
us in our experiences in life
that we don't speak about.
Things we don't say.
Things we don't talk about, but
the things that we know to be true,
but often only internally.
So we don't realize necessarily
this is something that we all share.
You know, and when each piece
of music has within it some --
well I'll say a great range
of expressive qualities
that go past our intellectual
experience and understanding
and touch the inner kind of core
of each person in different ways.
But it affirms for
them the existence
of this reality that they have.
And there's something
tremendously comforting about that.
And also gives you a sense
of community, you know,
and a sense that you're
not alone with that feeling
or that experience in your life.
>> Nicholas Brown: Thank you.
That's very insightful.
I appreciate it.
Anyone else have some thoughts?
You can say no.
That's okay.
>> Alexi Kenney: I was going
to say I mean just in terms
of my experience, I do a lot of
traveling to perform with orchestras
or recitals around the country.
And a lot of the time kind of
in the middle of the country
where I wouldn't necessarily
go on vacation
or travel too, particularly.
And I'm often asked to do some sort
of educational outreach
when I travel.
And this is something that
I've grown to really love.
Sometimes even more than
playing the concert itself.
Although, of course, I love
performing and all of that,
but there's something
incredibly important obviously
about playing for kids.
And I think a lot of that -- when
I play for a school, for instance,,
I find myself being as
passionate or even feel
like being more passionate is
so important, because, you know,
to go along with inspiration
and all of this, of course,
I agree that yes there's
this incredible quality
about music that is unspeakable..
You can't put it into words.
And that beauty for me keeps me
going as a musician day to day.
But for a group of kids who
are listening to music maybe
for the first time
listening to a violin player,
I think what touches somebody
is energy and raw kind
of that sort of inspiration.
Somebody is seeing somebody
very, very passionate
about something they love to do.
And I feel that's a great duty
for my life to bring to people,
especially to kids but also in
every performance, you know,
just giving it 120 percent
because why do it otherwise.
>> Robin Scott: Yeah.
You have you have the chance to
possibly really reach someone
who may never heard a violin or
any classical music, for instance,,
and then you really I think it helps
you find what you really want to say
in a way, because they don't
care about all the other details
that other professionals who might
listen to you, might care about.
And they also can tell --
I think they can see right
through fakery [laughs]
or disingenuous sorts of things.
And so you have to be really
honest and do your very best
to really command their attention.
That's difficult.
[laughs] But it's totally worth it.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
Zoltan, did you want
to add anything?
>> Zoltan Fejervan: I can
only agree with everybody.
It just comes to my mind what
Gabriel Garcia Marquez wrote
about him being a writer.
And I think he writes that you
shouldn't be a writer if you realize
that you can't live without writing.
So it's something similar
with the musician I think.
So we have to realize if you
can't live without making music,
that's like so if we can live
without making music then
let's stop making music.
And we certainly have to have a
very strong message in our playing.
That's what matters for sure.
>> Nicholas Brown: Thank you
for sharing those thoughts.
I think it means a lot for all of
us to hear about that from you,
and in a very thoughtful
way that probably puts
into words what we
experience in these concerts,
because a lot of us are regulars
and we share these moments
together we might never speak
about what happened.
We don't necessarily know
what the artist was intending,
but I guarantee that in the
concerts that really touch us,
whether it's you guys or another
ensemble, there are these moments
that as you said are really
affecting people in ways
that they didn't really
think could happen.
Well, I guess one more question
then we have to let them go.
So if you just wait
for the microphone.
The gentleman in the
corner over here.
>> I was wondering when you were
talking about the unsaid or portion
of the content of music,
do you communicate among your very
small community about that aspect
of the pieces you played together
so that you were all
communicating the same message?
>> Robin Scott: Absolutely.
>> Peter Stumpf: I'm sorry.
What is the question
specifically are we talking about?
>> Do you communicate
among yourselves
about the unspoken content
of the music you play,
so that you are a more
homogeneous community?
>> Peter Stumpf: No, we
don't speak about it.
[ Laughs ]
No, I mean actually we do.
We do. But I think it's
actually the same thing happening
in the group itself.
A lot of what we're doing we
couldn't actually talk about.
It's impossible.
And that's where the
mystery comes in.
How are we doing?
Like how does that even happen?
That's a real mystery, you know,
and I think we experience this
kind of thing all the time.
And sometimes we just don't
even think about the fact
that we're experiencing it, but we
are, even just amongst ourselves.
You know, because things change
from one orchestra to the next,
even from one minute to
the next in a rehearsal.
You couldn't always define
all of those elements
that are shifting and changing.
And it's just kind
of a real mystery.
You know, how did that happen.
I mean I had this experience
even very literally in a number
of instances in my life
where something changed
and there was an acknowledgement
that that had happened,
but nobody can really
define or say what it was.
You know, except that it was more of
a connection between the musicians.
>> Robin Scott: But also we do
absolutely talk about what sort
of quality what we want
to convey, so that we --
I think the effort of trying
to describe even these indescribable
things is very good to go
through because it makes you really
think about how you want to sound
and what you want to convey and
then if you do that also as a group,
then you can find that you have
a better more cohesive vision
for the piece.
So, yes, there's some things that
you can't always get 100 percent
with words to describe music,
but it's I think a good
exercise actually to go
as far as you can oftentimes.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
Well, thank you all
for your questions
and your attention this evening, and
thank you so much to the gentleman
up here for spending some time
with all of us and speaking.
And then we're very
much looking forward
to the non-speaking
portion of the evening.
[laughs] And we encourage
you if you are interested
in watching recent performances
of musicians from Marlboro
at the library to visit
our website loc.gov.
And in the search box type
in "musicians from Marlboro,"
and you will find the videos
from last year's two concerts
that were here at the library.
And then the concerts from
this season will be put
up in the next few months
for you to check out as well.
And do consider going up
to Marlboro for a weekend.
I think I'll probably be up there
this summer, and happy to hang
out with you guys if
you're up there.
Thank you so much.
Thank you gents, and we'll
see you in a little bit.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.